اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم كاميرون يؤكد الجزيره
ضروره تحقيق وقف اطلاق نار انساني فوري في
غزه يفضي في النهايه الى وقف دائم وسط
خلافات داخليه وزير في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يحمل نتنياهو مسؤوليه الاخفاق
في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر وعشيه نطق محكمه
العدل الدوليه بالحكم في قضيه ارتكاب
اسرائيل جرائم اباده جماعيه فريق من مئات
المحامين يقدمون ادله جديده للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ويقولون ان اسرائيل
تستهدف المدنيين وتدمر مقومات الحياه
تجدون المزيد من اخبار غزه في رابط
بالتعليق الاول النيت يبدا اكبر مناوره
عسكريه يجريها منذ الحرب البارده مع
مغادره سفينه حربيه امريكيه الولايات
المتحده لعبور المحيط الاطلسي الى اراضي
الحلف في اوروبا حيث سيشارك نحو 90 ال
جندي في المناورات المصممه لاختبار دفاعات
النيتو في مواجهه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا حسب القائد الاعلى للحلف في
اوروبا تقرير صادر عن مجموعه سيتي جروب
المصرفيه الامريكيه يحذر من احتمال ارتفاع
اسعار النفط العالميه الى 90 دولارا
للبرميل بسبب استمرار حرب غزه وتصاعد
التترات الجيو سياسيه في الشرق الاوسط
وتحديدا في البحر
الاحمر اكس تطلق ميزه مفاتيح المرور على
هواتف ايفون كخيار لتسجيل الدخول الى
الحسابات دون الحاجه الى تذكر كلمه المرور
المنسيه او اعاده تعيينها الميزه تعتمد
على التصديق البيومتري لهويه المستخدم
وتتطلب تاكيد الهويه ببصمه الاصبع او
خاصيه تعرف الوجوه خلاف لكلمات المرور
التقليديه التي تعتمد على استخدام الحروف
والارقام
والرموز الى
اللقاء